Nigeria is a country famous for its film
industry
[Music]
I know by now you know that India and
the United States are the two countries
that produce the most movies in the
world while Nigeria could very well be
in third place in 2022 alone they
produced over 2 500 movies in fact as we
talk about Hollywood or Bollywood we
could also talk about Nollywood I know
what you're thinking Nigerian Cinema I
didn't even know that existed and to be
honest it's not surprising we're talking
about very low budget films which are
only consumed in Africa but this is a
good example of all the potential this
country has and how little we know about
it Nigeria is not just another African
country it is the country with the
largest economy in Africa we're talking
about a full-fledged oil power with the
potential to become a new Russia however
I'm sure that when you think of Nigeria
the first damage that comes to mind is
this one
that's right it's also the country of
Boku Haram the country where they went
as far as kidnapping 276 girls in 2014.
well visual politic viewers the sad
reality is that for all the potential
Nigeria has today it's a miserable
country no matter how much income oil
generates 40 of the population lives in
absolute poverty we're talking about
more than 80 million people because yes
Nigeria is the seventh most populous
country in the world they have more than
206 million inhabitants but that's not
all pay attention to this graph here you
can see the enormous potential of this
country it is the ninth country in the
world in terms of income from crude oil
exports and in the ranking of countries
with the most reserves it ranks 11th
just behind the United States so here
comes Nigeria's big opportunity the
European Union needs new oil suppliers
and Nigeria could be one of the most
significant what's more this country has
a constitution an estate structure that
is theoretically Democratic something
that is not at all common in Africa what
it does have in common with other
neighboring countries however is
corruption Louisville to turnout limited
several Liberties and weak institutions
that cause Nigerian democracy to be
considered very weak but despite all
this the question is could oil and an
improvement of their democracy really
left Nigerians out of poverty could
Nigeria save Europe with its dinosaur
juice could even become a kind of
African Russia without the problems of
the original Russia of course today
we're going to answer all of these
questions but first let's look at a bit
of History
one country 250 ethnic groups
Nigeria is a country you've probably
heard of before after all it is the
seventh most populous country in the
world and one of the most oil rich but
what exactly is Nigeria you see Nigeria
is inhabited by approximately 250
different ethnic groups each with its
own traditions and languages the houses
the egbos 30 rubus and hundreds more are
distributed throughout this territory
well when the British arrived here and
established a colonial regime in the
middle of the 19th century the
differences between the majority ethnic
groups did not take long to become
apparent
in fact the British divided the colony
into three regions the north of the
hausa and the Muslim Fulani the egbo
East and the Yoruba West who were mainly
Christian and do you think they treated
all three equally well not at all the
Golden Child of the Empire and the
colony was the Muslim North where the
emirs helped the British forces in
exchange for luxuries anyway it was the
usual Colonial story basically in the
end the British opted to Grant
Independence to Nigeria in 1960 but not
because they were tired of them but
because they were already activist
groups pushing too hard for example the
action group and the National Council of
Nigeria and the cameroonians however you
can imagine that a country composed of
250 ethnic groups is going to have
problems they're hardly going to end up
understanding each other politically and
you know what that's exactly what
happened and it didn't take long for it
to happen either six years after
Independence the first coup d'etat took
place since then Nigeria has been
plunged into chaos up to six coup
d'etats between 1966 and 1999 and
constant tension between the Islamic
North and the Christian South but there
were not only coup d'etats they also had
a civil war
in 1967 in present-day tongo they
reported the killing of citizens from
the northern region of Nigeria and the
Eastern region the citizens of the north
became so Furious that they started
attacking and masking the igbos in the
north not surprisingly many of these
egbos returned to their region of origin
the east in the same year Lieutenant
Colonel ujukwu declared the independence
of the region making it the Republic of
Biafra well at first it seemed that
Biafra would succeed after all it was
Nigeria's most oil-rich region but its
dream of Independence eventually turned
into a nightmare they ended up totally
surrounded and isolated resulting in a
famine that killed more than 3 000
people a day in Biafra including 1 000
children and remember we're talking
about every single day
starvation is a weapon of war and we
have every intention of using it against
the rebels Alison Aida head of Nigerian
delegation Naomi peace talks July 1968.
in the end Biafra surrendered and became
part of Nigeria again but as you can
imagine the egbos were never going to
forget this conflict however despite all
this in 1999 the situation slowly began
to change after the death of the
dictator abacha the so-called Fourth
Republic began in Nigeria
[Music]
after several failed constitutions and
republics completely dominated by the
Army the Fourth Republic seemed to bring
in New Hope and the same year new
elections were held and the son of the
ex-dictator obasanjo won and since then
in successive elections only obasanjo's
chosen ones have won all from the
people's Democratic party the main
conservative and economically Liberal
Party in the country however always
amidst accusations of electoral fraud
and political violence nevertheless in
2015 Nigerians finally decided to put
their foot down Nigeria election
muhammadu buhari wins presidency exactly
visual politic viewers in 2015 the
Nigerian people swung left and elected
the opposition party's leader Social
Democrat muhammadu buhari so why was
this good news no it's not because we
like the politician or anything like
that in this case it's good news that
for the first time in history Nigeria
had a peaceful transition of power in
other words it looked like democracy may
actually be working for the first time
in this country so the question is is
this really a trend that is going to
develop well let's find out
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
over the years Nigeria has become the
leading dinosaur juice exporting country
in Africa in fact between 2015 and 2019
it was producing more than 2 million
barrels of crude oil per day to give you
an idea Angola which is its main
competitor in Africa only exported 1.4
million barrels per day in 2019. so we
could be talking about a veritable
African Russia Nigeria has maintained
its exports based on dinosaur juice
since 1977 when it created its
state-owned company but the reality is
that Nigerian oil began to be exploited
much earlier
foreign
1937 when Nigeria was still a British
colony the British oil company's shell
and BP began exploring the territory for
oil in 1953 they found small quantities
that they could not yet trade however in
1956 they found their first commercially
viable Black Gold Mine it was in the
city of oliburi in the Nigeria Delta the
most oil-rich area of the country these
companies knew their Investments were
fully secured so they decided to start
refining the crude they were extracting
in 1965 they built the first Refinery
and from then on more companies arrived
Chevron and Texaco from the US along
with the Italian Egypt foreign
[Music]
for the oil companies right no doubt
about it we are used to seeing energy
resources firmly in the hands of the
state of the exporting country these are
the models of Russia and Saudi Arabia
for example but in Nigeria things are
much more flexible yes it is true the
current Constitution gives the Nigerian
State full control over its natural and
energy resources but the reality is that
you have never been afraid to sell more
exploitation rates for juicy paychecks
so it is no wonder that Nigeria has 159
oil fields and 1 500 extraction Wells
and of course many of them do not belong
to the states most of them belong to
foreign companies in fact according to
the Nigerian oil investment manager 98
of the sectors oil reserves and
operating assets are in the hands of six
Western private oil companies the most
important of which is shell and not only
that between shell Exxon Chevron Egypt
and Texaco they own up to six oil export
terminals as well as several pipelines
but make no mistake about it the
Nigerian government is no fool Nigeria
has not allowed foreign companies to
control the entire production chain the
refineries belong to the state remember
that Refinery that shell and BP started
building in 1965 the state bought it in
1978 and almost all the big refineries
are state-owned in the fact that oil has
undoubtedly become the country's biggest
export it accounts for more than 70 of
all foreign sales now what does this all
mean though well if you've been
following visualpolitik for a long time
you can already imagine corruption
Nigeria is plagued with problems around
the oil sector it will come as no
surprise if I tell you that one of the
biggest scourges in Nigeria is
corruption and not just any corruption
but corruption specifically in the oil
sector and if the impact of corruption
in Nigeria were not so great we wouldn't
even be telling you about it but the
fact is more than 20 of the country's
GDP goes down the drain precisely for
this reason just to give you an idea the
country's entire public debt could be
paid off with what it loses due to
corruption the problem is that both
politicians and businessmen have
benefited from corruption in the sector
for example Nigeria's former oil
Minister dayizani Allison maduke was
convicted of allowing no less than 20
billion dollars to disappear from the
Nigerian National Oil Company even the
richest person in the country and in
Africa aliko dangote a businessman has
been accused of buying favors from
former president obasanjo in 2003.
Interruption has meant that Nigerian
citizens do not often see a single
dollar from the sale of the country's
crude oil in fact according to the World
Bank only one percent of Nigeria's
entire population has benefited from the
oil sector this is not only bad news for
Nigerians it is also bad news for the
oil companies themselves in many parts
of Nigeria people are beginning to
vandalize Wells and steal crude oil and
fuels from the already dilapidated
refineries and Pipelines
therefore we're not surprised to come
across news stories like this one
Nigeria's illegal oil refineries dirty
dangerous lucrative in many towns and
Villages such as those in the Nitro
Delta citizens are stealing crude oil
and vandalizing oil installations which
makes sense for many of them this is the
only way to get by in a country with an
unemployment rate of 33 which Rises to
54 for young people corruption has
therefore led many communities
throughout the south of the country to
steal crude oil and refine it themselves
but that's not the only problem check
this out
[Music]
a failed state
do you remember Biafra the territory
that tried to gain independence from
Nigeria in 1967. but when we told you
earlier that the egg boss had not
forgotten what happened during the Civil
War we meant that many of them are still
around today in fact the Igbo
secessionists have their own militant
group a group that is now blacklisted as
a terrorist group in Nigeria do you know
why because the Nigerian government also
accuses them of stealing crude oil and
sabotaging refineries whoever the case
the one thing is certain the oil thefts
in the country have caused the Nigerian
state to lose millions of dollars to
give you an idea some estimates indicate
that since 2008 losses due to theft
sabotage and the resulting drop in
production May reach 100 billion dollars
so it is logical that the country's
leaders and international investors are
worried but it is not the only terrorist
group from the country in fact it is far
from it and it's not even the most
bloodthirsty by far to tell the truth
the most feared of all has been one that
many of you I'm sure will know Boko
Haram
Boko Haram was started in 1995 as a non
violent Muslim youth group however over
the years considering that Nigeria's
drift was totally contrary to the wishes
of you know Allah they began their
crusade to turn the country into an
Islamic state governed by Sharia law and
in order to achieve this in 2002 they
began to adopt violent methods its first
Target was the city of maiduguri and its
expansion began throughout the rest of
the country especially in the northeast
of Nigeria however it was not until 2009
that it began to gain the strength that
has made them the most feared terrorist
group in the country and one of the most
bloodthirsty in the entire sahil region
their narrative appeals to the most
disadvantaged sectors of the country
this is how they have come to recruit
more than 40
000 Fighters
but hold on a minute because Boko Haram
is not the only terrorist group plaguing
Nigeria take a look at this map
[Music]
foreign
to the problems with Boko Haram and the
secessionist movement for Biafra the
Nigerian government has other open
fronts from the gangs in the northwest
of the country to Yoruba secessionism in
the South such as that of Biafra or the
conflict between Muslim herdsmen and
Christian Farmers that runs throughout
the whole country so is Nigeria a failed
State most analysts have no doubt it is
the Nigerian government is not in
control of each area dominated by Boko
Haram nor can intervene in the conflict
between herders and farmers in this case
we are talking about a conflict that has
killed more than 20 000 people since
1999. however there are others who are
not so fixated on the state's control
over its entire Sovereign territory that
is why we have also heard analysts who
prefer to say that is not a failed state
but a failing state which is not the
same thing what's more they say that
Nigeria could begin to function for
three reasons there is greater political
stability there is greater tolerance
among ethnic groups and there is a
stronger Nigerian identity but the
reality is that as of today the Nigerian
government cannot control all of its
territory so it's a failed State however
things can change the war in Ukraine has
provided a window of opportunity for
this country but what is happening in
Ukraine have to do with Nigeria or pay
attention to this news Russia to ban oil
sales under price cap Kremlin says
Moscow ready to reduce output to
compensate for lost exports says Deputy
Prime Minister Alexander Novak Russia
has already communicated that it will
not give more oil to the European Union
if it puts a price cap on it this means
one thing Europe needs new suppliers of
dinosaur juice this could be Nigeria's
chance to start turning things around
also Nigerian crude is very similar in
quality to Saudi Arabian crude that is
the best quality easy to refine and
relatively cheap to extract Nigeria
could start making its wells work
relentlessly however there are several
problems that could threaten this dream
[Music]
the main one is that their production of
barrels per day depends on what OPEC
plus allows and taking into account
their recent Trend they will continue to
reduce the production in order to raise
the prices even more in addition the
rampant corruption in the country will
continue to make this dream impossible
with the more money that is stolen and
the less that reaches the citizens the
more theft and sabotage there will be in
other words less money it's kind of a
vicious cycle finally the refineries and
some pipelines are in terrible condition
government funds go through so much
bureaucracy that maintenance of oil
facilities is often almost non-existent
and naturally the worst the
infrastructure the lower the production
Nigeria has taken the first steps to
solving some of these problems by
achieving some democratic stability but
we will have to see what happens in next
year elections because Northern
Nigeria's history we would not be
surprised if there is another coup
d'etat but now the questions are over to
you will Nigeria manage to put an end to
corruption and terrorism will it become
the new Russia for the European Union
will it manage to improve the living
conditions of its citizens you can leave
me your answers in the comments below as
always don't forget that here on
visualpolitik we release new videos
every single week subscribe to this
Channel and hit the little bell button
down there so you don't miss any of our
updates if you like this video like it
so we know all the best and I'll see you
next time
[Music]